تحضيرات المغرب قال هناك محددات يجب
احترامها ليس فقط للمغرب لاي دوله
ستذهب الى قمه عربيه في دوله اخرى
اتحدث مع الخارطه اللي هي مساله مهمه جدا
بالنسبه
لا علاقه لها بهذه المحطه بالمقابل كان
هناك اعتذار من هاي المحطه على ما حدث الم
يرضيكم ذلك بمعنى اخر عندما تم الحديث عن
احتواء التوتر لم ينتهي هذا التوتر اساسي
همم
المغرب قال هذه شهور بانه هناك ضوابط يجب
ان تحترم
مطلقه ضمانات
لما وقع الامر كان هناك اولا استغراب لان
هذه ماشي مسائل يعني لماذا لم يتم التلاعب
بخارطه تونس الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لا اعلم انه كنت هناك اجمل اجمل خريطه نحن
لسنا في في الندوه تعلقه بالجغرافيا ونحن
طبعا اجتماع الدول الاعضاء موضوع خارطه
انا سمعت عن طريق بيان لجامعه الدول
العربيه ان تقليد
الممارسه ممارسه الجامعه العربيه الدول
العربيه
في الجامعه هناك خارطه واحده
للوطن العربي بدون حدود هذا هو الرمز
المستعمل في جامعه الدول العربيه ليس هناك
تحديث لدول بعينها ما حدودها الدوليه فهذا
ما يستعمل في سياق الجماعه العربيه اما
بالنسبه للاماكن التي تديرها الدوله
الجزائريه فلم تكون هناك اي خريطه على
الاطلاق
اذان الموضوع
الاول موضوع